So
look at me with that word I became a
look coach I'm the mother and they've been
15 years old
Ivan has autism he doesn't speak and
communicates through an ipad where
his whole universe of words and images is
I received his diagnosis when he was
two and a half years old  and to this day I still remember
that moment with a lot of pain with my
husband we felt very lost
we didn't know where to start
there was no internet like now we couldn't
ignore information so these
first steps were pure intuition
iván didn't hold his gaze he had
lost his  words he said he did not
respond to his name and to anything we
did to them as if words were
noises
the only way I had to know
what was happening to him what he felt was by
looking into his eyes
that bridge was rock like showing him the
villalba when he associates things that  he
liked them
així he didn't look and we were together
so I dedicated myself to following him in those things
so that each time we unite more and more
moments of looks we spend  hours and
hours when he spotted her with her older sister
alexia and in this round of haiti this
rag was looking for
me there at that moment i felt that she was
river we also have a record of now in
the pool she always had a very
strong passion for water
i  I agree that he was two and a half years old and
one winter day with a lot of rain he
was taking an indoor pool
because we weren't even there those days
we were going down the highway and
I took the wrong exit and there he started
crying uncontrollably until
he resumed  road and just then he
calmed down how was it possible that at two
and a half years he did not respond to his name but
in the middle of this rain it is flour that
I could not see anything he was able to
perfectly recognize the road
there I realized that they are going to have a
exceptional visual memory and that this
was going to happen and entrance door
so I started taking pictures of everything and
showing him life he continues to show himself
photo by photo and still today he is still  When
the way they went tells us what
he wants is what he needs and
also what he always is but not
only was the rival look
[Music]
there was also the lives of others
how to get them not only to look at the
auc and  added but they look at him with
everything he can give with everything he
is capable of chance with the things he
likes the things he doesn't like any of
us but for that I also
had to do my part I had to
to encourage us to let go and it was very difficult for me
iván was 11 years old
and this is a treatment very close to
home
in another neighborhood and one afternoon while I
had been waiting for him for some time in a
grocery store he meets a neighborhood grocery store that
has a little of everything and between buying and
buying he likes it  chatting with josé g
the owner of contra iván who had
autism and that I wanted him to take
care of her walking alone down the street without
anyone helping me and I decided to
ask him if the games
were going to be held in the afternoon he could come help the
order  to the shelves of water bottles
because he loved ordering and as a reward
buying some chocolate cookies
his favorite recipes he
immediately said yes and that was how
for a year
iván came to jose's greengrocery
helped him see the shelves of bottles
of water  water that was left with the labels
perfectly enchiladas
millimetrically to the same side and he
left happily with his
chocolate cookies more jose is not an expert in
autism it is not necessary to be experts in
anything and to be no feat to include
out
we simply have to be
more
like this is none  fails
we just have to be close
if something scares us or we don't understand it
let's ask let's be curious but never
indifferent let's have the courage to
look each other in the eye because with our
gaze we can open a world to another
fact